el estado plurinacional la coexistencia
de diversas naciones y pueblos en el
marco de la unidad del estado todos
estos tendrían el derecho a la autonomía
pero reitera que en ningún caso el
ejercicio de ésta podrá atentar en
contra del carácter único e indivisible
del estado de chile ni permitirá la
secesión territorial la democracia
paritaria 50 por ciento de todos los
órganos del estado tendrán que ser
ocupados por mujeres según el artículo 6
del documento esto aplicaría incluso
para las empresas públicas además el
estado debería promover adoptar medidas
para alcanzar la igualdad de género el
sistema político de 35 a 30 años pasaría
a ser la edad mínima para postularse a
la presidencia un cargo para el que el
nuevo texto permite una reelección
consecutiva y no alternada como en la
actualidad
uno de los puntos inéditos en la
eliminación del senado de la república
este sería reemplazado por la cámara de
las regiones que estaría conformada por
al menos tres representantes de cada una
de las regiones del país así el poder
legislativo chileno pasaría de tener un
congreso nacional compuesto de la cámara
de diputados y el senado a tener un
congreso para la formulación de leyes y
una cámara de las regiones destinada a
revisar ciertas de las normas
derechos humanos la nueva carta magna
establece a chica como estado social y
democrático de derecho con el deber de
proveer bienes y servicios para asegurar
los derechos de las personas resalta lo
expuesto con respecto a la educación la
define de carácter laico y gratuito
mientras que lo estipulado para los
derechos reproductivos ha generado
controversia se establece que deben ser
garantizadas las condiciones para un
embarazo una interrupción voluntaria del
mismo así como partos y paternidad
voluntarios y protegidos